we're asked to solve for X and we have
9x squared minus 42 x plus 29 is equal
to negative 20 now you might be tempted
immediately to try to factor the
left-hand side of this equation and get
the product of two binomials and that
they equal negative 20 but if you think
about it that's not going to help you
much that product of two binomials is
only useful if they're equal to zero
then you can say well one or both of
them need to be equal to zero but they
can't you can't make any statement like
that if they both equal negative 20 so
the first thing we want to do here is
not to factor this left-hand side but to
make sure that we have a quadratic
equation equaling 0 we want a 0 on one
side of this equation and the best way I
can think of doing that is just to add
20 to both sides of this equation so if
we add 20 to both sides of this equation
then we are left with on the left hand
side 9x squared 9x squared minus 40 2x
plus 49 is equal to 0 now we have a
quadratic we have a quadratic expression
equaling 0 now we have a nice quadratic
equation and we can factor this thing on
the left hand side now we could factor
it by grouping but you might immediately
something might immediately pop out at
you and you know what you see numbers
like 9 + 49 those are perfect squares so
maybe this whole expression is the
perfect square of some binomial so let's
think about it a little bit 9 squared is
3x is 3x squared 9 squared is 3x squared
+ 49 is 7 is 7 squared or negative 7
squared let's see negative 42 negative
42 is 2 3 times 7 is 21 21 times 2 is
positive 42 but if we make this a
negative 7 if we make this a negative 7
because negative 7 would also work
negative 7 squared is also 49 then 3
times negative 7 times 2 is negative 42
let me write that down
42 is 2 times
three times negative seven so this fits
the pattern of a perfect square so the
left-hand side of this equation right
here we can write it as the left-hand
side we can write it as 3x minus 7 3x
minus F we could write it as 3x minus 7
times 3x minus 7 or just 3x minus 7
squared and that is going to be equal to
0
now we essentially only have one
expression equaling 0 times itself so
the only way that's going to be equal to
0 is if that expression is equal to 0 3x
minus 7 needs to be equal to 0 and now
we can just solve for X let's add 7 to
both sides of this equation and we get
3x these cancel out is equal to 7 divide
both sides by 3 and we get X is equal to
7 thirds x is equal to let me just write
it here X is equal to 7 over 3